people magazine called our next guest
the very best singing impressionist in
the world and this hall of fame singer
is back in las vegas at the italian
american club with a brand new show
called one more for the road here he is
it's mr bob anderson welcome to the show
hey man what a pleasure it is to be here
i love uh vegas you know i was
i lived down here for 32 years just
about a mile from here did you really
yeah yeah it was great i love it i miss
it well last time you're in town you're
at the palazzo yes sold out shows for
almost a year doing your frank sinatra
show yeah i saw that show it was one of
the first nights you blew me away i
thought frank sinatra was on the stage
he's still alive he's on stage you're an
amazing performer well that's that's
very sweet of you to say that he's uh
you know he's really a difficult guy to
kind of do if you're really going to try
to do it right you know it's uh
probably worked at it you know i worked
at that with trying to do him
for a year i worked
i got downstairs at five in the morning
i had microphones on
four times i would say for a year i it
took me two hours a day to get it right
you have his mannerisms down but this
show is a little bit different you're
doing some sinatra songs how's the show
this new show different uh this one's
different because what i'm doing is i'm
going to uh
do all the guys that there's a bunch of
entertainers that people forget about
but these people are who made this town
the entertainment capital of the world
and that's the people that i'm doing in
my show i'm going to do bobby daron and
sammy davis and dean martin and robert
goulet and steve lawrence steven edie
and jack jones and tom jones and i'm
gonna do all those people for them uh
because those people really made this
town what it is
if las vegas would have a mountain
rushmore those are the names that would
be on the mount russia you're exactly
right they would yes sir and i'm going
to do you know i'm going to do sinatra
in there too and you know like i said
you know tony bennett and uh
got to do all that the fall once in my
life you know all that stuff and i just
love doing it and then i sing as myself
to i'm a jazz singer who happens to do
impressions
and it was merv griffin that started me
into that and that's the road he took me
on and that's where i'm staying you know
we lost frank in that with the mid 90s
did he ever see your act or see you
performance i've worked uh four shows
with frank sinatra did you really yeah
yeah frank sanders daughter uh nancy got
me in the business uh first time i went
to her house he came around uh he was
serving dinner so he sat down and gave
us all our food and we sat there and i
yeah i knew him uh a few different times
did shows with him
uh i he was just a great guy he came in
and one day he stood up and uh at steve
wynn's place and he stood up in the
middle of my show he says
this kid's got a hell of an act don't he
and i'll never forget when he said it
and i thought okay frank said i yeah you
know no no i didn't say that but i uh he
was spot on oh he was spot on he was
beautiful and dane martin was sitting
with him oh my god
yeah when sammy davis had just died and
passed away so ella fitzgerald and and
the two of them came along with johnny
mathis and a couple of other people
and dean martin i was doing sammy davis
jr like this yeah i'm gonna do sammy and
dean martin is saying hey don't we don't
want we heard that song enough i don't
want to sing that song now he had his
foot on the stage right here it was a
short thing so i was saying i went like
that i
i kicked his foot off the stage man and
it was dean martin's and i said get off
the stage you ain't working this show
dude and sinatra laughed mentally cried
and we just
we had a great time and that was a nice
time meeting him i love it bob thank you
so much i'll be telling some of these
stories at the show you got to go see
him one more for the road at the
showroom inside the italian american
club on wednesday and thursday june 29th
and 30th amazing stuff mercedes over to
you
thus